[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys okay so me and tag are
playing this really fun game he has like
this little gun let me show you where
you load it up with these balls and then
you like you shoot it out
okay and what we're doing is we're
getting all of our our shoes
and
we're only using the ones that have like
a hole in it like we're not using
sandals um and then we're shooting them
over here to see who can make the balls
into the shoes
and taika is
whipping my butt taika is winning
no yeah you're kicking my butt like
you're beating me
that's what that means
yeah you're kicking my butt okay load my
gun up for me dude
he's really good i gotta show you what
it's like okay let me set up the camera
oh monkey there's one right here
you forgot one let me set up the camera
so you guys can see what we're talking
about okay we're really good
here we go
all right so i'll talk taika
loads up
his gun you see the little balls there
um i'm gonna set up over here we got his
shoes we got a crock we got my vans we
got papa shoes
so they're all types of sizes
here we go he's really good you guys
[Music]
okay go for it
let's go dude
that's close
it's really good
[Applause]
it's okay it's okay
you guys know you got like four more
oh my god it really wants to go and pop
a shoe
you're in dude
right section you're ready close
there's one more there's one more
push it forward no that way yeah like
that
go
hey that went on the stairs good job
mama's going to beat you up now
it's mama's turn
you go get it
okay so for halloween we uh santa
bought taika this dinosaur egg
and we've had it in water for about two
days and the dinosaur
you're right three days uh and the
dinosaur finally hatched okay take it
out that okay yeah spilled it you can
spill the water and then we're gonna
open the okay
go for it
the whole thing yeah good job
good job
you can go faster if you want
okay let's see what kind of dinosaur you
got
a t-rex
are you sure about that
how do you know so much
yeah let's crack it open
can i feel it
what is it ew it's like this foam
okay
yeah you could
oh whoa that's crazy
you got a new dinosaur dude
oh my god
sorry okay
whoa look at that
so he's stuck in this he's stuck in
there yeah he's too sticky keep ripping
it keep breaking the
egg oh okay
okay let me see
oh yucky this thing is rubber or
something okay you hold it and i'll pull
it
go
pull let's give him a bath oh jesus
yeah let's wash him up give him his
first bath
what are you gonna name him
[Music]
a baby
let's put some water in it you don't
want to give him a name
i know but you can call him like buddy
the t-rex or something or
junior
i put water on yeah what is it
the dinosaur no they put on the back oh
i see
you like him yeah he's so cute let's
draw him up okay let's dry him up
oh no but this is
no it's wet it's okay it's damp it's not
wet it's just a little damp
papa coming to the rescue with some good
old in and out
thank you so much because i'm starving i
am starving too and dino
uh we are starving it's only it's not
even it's barely 11 minutes
yeah
it's because we only ate one meal
yesterday yeah i was about to say that
oh okay that's all you're giving us got
it
yeah so yesterday we uh did our get
close podcast episode can't wait for you
guys to hear it with joe
the fam joe
and um we spent all day with him
yesterday but so we did the pocket so we
did the podcast i'm getting ahead of
myself early in the morning and then we
wrapped up at around like 12 we went to
two different restaurants one of them
was completely packed the other one we
had to wait i don't know how long and
then by the time we sat down to eat it
was probably like 1 30 so we had lunch
and then um
we sat and we talked for hours and i
think it was about three or four that we
went
after having lunch
we went to go get ice cream and then
after ice cream it was we stayed and we
talked for another couple hours we got
home like around six or seven and then
we hung out a little bit
and then we went to sleep and then this
morning we're like why are we so hungry
and it's like
because we only ate one meal yesterday
so yes papa ooh
[Applause]
back at my favorite store in the whole
wide world rei
because we're going snowboarding and
what's super cuny is we're going
snowboarding as a family tomorrow that
little duty duty over there is going to
take ski lessons because he's too young
for snowboarding because i think for
snowboarding you need to be six or seven
but ski you could start at four tomorrow
i'm gonna go snowboarding with joe
and this ain't no like
la snow resort when we went to go visit
i'm like this is cold cold like this
feels like a utah colorado snow resort
so
i have like la snowboard type clothes
and i'm like i don't think he's gonna
cut it because i was kind of like
shivering in my trousers
you guys are making some cutie sounds
okay dude
yes
just sitting in the chair oh you love
that little one huh oh yeah we need a
couple of uh camping chairs too
pick out some that you like we just
probably need like two of them you want
to get it now yeah let's grab it we're
over here
we've gotta get that one the rocky one i
want this one peppa you like down
because it rocks around
i don't know anything about just get
whatever is comfy okay yeah whatever is
the comfiest this one's pretty nice too
also got pistons look at that holy moly
yeah whatever is comfy
oh okay are you okay dude what happened
who's
ah sad news no way so they said they
don't carry ski and snowboard jackets
and stuff here because the season's easy
because the seasons here are
unpredictable sometimes so sometimes the
season will come and go and they'll just
have to like ship it somewhere else um i
do know that yeah i do know vegas has a
ton of other actual snowboard
stores and all that yeah so i'm gonna
look on my phone real quick okay
i think joe told us that yesterday too
so you think you can do what she's doing
let me see show me
nailed it
nailed it
yep
yep
did you just tickle her feet
he
told me
tell me i think it was meant to be
because remember i was telling you i was
looking for overall pants yeah but wait
if these aren't
oh and you just wear like a thing under
yeah because if i'm gonna tumble and
there's real powder i'll get in every
single crevice you're telling me i got
taika in my i got taika and myself
it's why do you say it's large because
there's no other ones this is the only
one
okay
hey is that you no who's that bloopy
bloopy it was bloopy blippy's cousin
yeah that's something people tell you
it's not bloopy when people tell me no i
still have to double check i gotta see
for myself good for you
puppies puppy baby
so papa's having a fashion show he can't
decide between
what this like it's like a brick or a
rust yeah like a rust
this really bright orangey red
or this uh royal blue my heart
might be there
then go with it what do you think trust
your pet even though i'm gonna be like
who cares kool-aid man who cares trust
your gut
go with it really yeah just pick it
don't think too much just do it oh
that's not north face it's rei so i love
res
but you know me like i got a match with
the brands and i got north face tents oh
well then that's it huh
decision made
is anyone home
nope no one's home
is it too bright
too bright for who
for the sun nope
it is safe i guess i'm stuck out in the
snow though it is very safe
oh no no no no you're going to fall
beautiful
you're going to fall
i'll figure it out
to be continued
so what are we going with so i'm gonna
go with this one
um
because for me i like i like stuff to
match so if i'm gonna get north face
pants
gotta get the north face top and what
was cool i saw this it just caught my
eye in the clearance section and you
know it's meant to be because there's
also north face
and there's also my size and there's
only one left wow
so gotta get all this
look at all this cuny stuff mama's
packing in there oh no
of course
we don't have fire you need fire for
this we're gonna be in the snow
ah it's okay thank you mama's packing
all these cuny snacks yeah cause when
you go snowboarding usually like the
cafeterias have like a nasty cafeteria
food so of course i'm bringing the
homies
the homies that hook it up
i'm so proud of them you're the best
mama ever bringing kenji bang noodles
nang shim yep
you're the best you're the best mama you
know that i'm all right
you know all that yummy food just for
one day of class
at this little duty
it's for everybody oh if you're going
with joe and hannah
we don't need this baby i want that okay
we'll put it in a bag then well one of
the one of the other which one
is this chocolate covered oreos
[Music]
and i brought out the big guns i know
mama gets cold so we have a little
electric blanket so you plug this into
the car you turn it on and the mom will
be nice and warm and toasty mama's a
little chicken when it comes to the cold
so i always gotta take care of her
what do you got going on over there oh
i am trying to make sure i have tyka
covered and warm because the last thing
i want is a cold baby you did a good job
last time we went he didn't complain
about the cold once
um yeah so i have a process
so the process here is so this is typo
size
all spiderman stuff yep
so this is his side so i'm just making
sure i don't forget anything so this is
what he's going to put on
this his jam is jams like a few pairs of
socks you put them all on on the same
time no no no so he'll start with this
in the car yeah it's really comfy yeah
so we'll start with this in the car also
it's not all like all stuffed
exactly and then once we get to the
mountain i'll take this off this will be
his base layer yeah um i'll probably put
two socks on him just because he has
bigger shoes and he's gonna be in the
snow a lot longer this time so i want
his feet to really be insulated yeah i
have an extra pair of socks because
we're playing with snow aka frozen water
yeah so i expect things to get wet and
the worst thing is to have
wet
feet yeah so i'm bringing extra pounds
and it gets cold yeah extra pair of
socks for him yeah once we're in the
snow he's gonna get out of this and he's
gonna go immediately into this
um with this i might i need to get a
sweater just in case even though i feel
like this is more than enough but i'd
rather be over prepared than
underprepared yeah so i'll probably get
like a little um like a crew neck type
sweater
um jacket he has his beanie
and glasses low mittens yeah i'll
probably bring his shoes up here now
i'll leave them down there
um i'll probably have him in two pairs
of shoes the ones in the car yeah and
then his hiking boots
do you need anything to pack all these
like luggage yeah i have it but i like
i'm a visual person you're a good one so
i have to see it and like visualize him
every step of like waking up having
breakfast to like
driving in the car to like getting out
of the car to getting out of the white
clothes into so like i have to have it
all laid out just to take care of all my
stuff like this
um i don't know whoever the adult in
your life is which i think is yourself
nope it's
i have the same for mine
see i have a onesie two
cuny yeah
all right
one of
the cutiest things
that i like to do and maybe only i find
it cuny
is watching tycho watch his favorite
movie because he's watched it 7 000
times now where he knows every single
line and he still loves it
no matter how many times i get hit i
he's a good guy huh
peterby parker yeah
yeah
yeah peter peter parker is your head
peter paul
just put the little duty mahuti to sleep
and that means we're gonna go to sleep
and i'm really excited tomorrow because
we're gonna go snowboarding and tech is
gonna learn how to ski and i have my
stuff ready over there
as you can see i have the most important
part
so i take care of myself
and marvel takes care of herself and
taika sounds really fair to me
and
i'll see you guys tomorrow good night